[Música]
inició en Bali la Cumbre del g20 previo
a la apertura se produjo un histórico
momento Joe biden y pienso subieron su
primer encuentro los líderes rebajaron
las tensiones pero mantuvieron sus
diferencias sobre Taiwán chile dijo a
wyden que se trata de una línea roja que
no debe cruzar
el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador minimizó las protestas que
se registraron el domingo para rechazar
su propuesta de reforma al Instituto
Nacional electoral y a otros 17
artículos de la constitución sus
opositores lo ven como una movida para
perpetuarse en el poder
hacia alrededor de dos meses Cuba aprobó
en referendo el nuevo código de familias
una legislación impulsada por el
oficialismo que por primera vez amplía
los derechos para La minoría trans y
avala los matrimonios homosexuales
cambiando la vida de miles de parejas
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundo soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Bali en
Indonesia donde inició la Cumbre del g20
previo a este comienzo tuvo lugar un
encuentro entre los presidentes de
Estados Unidos Joe biden y de China
chilling Pink quienes estuvieron su
primera reunión como mandatarios dicha
Cumbre estuvo enfocada en rebajar la
atención entre las potencias económicas
pero dejó en evidencia críticas a
Beijing en materia de derechos humanos y
advertencias a Washington sobre la línea
roja que atravesaría si Se involucra en
temas relacionados con Taiwán
evitar que la competencia se convierta
en el conflicto más temido fue la
premisa del primer cara a cara del
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden y
su homólogo chino chilling Pink
creo que el mundo Espera que China y
Estados Unidos desempeña en papeles
clave y aborden los desafíos globales
desde el cambio climático hasta la
alimentación y la seguridad
la situación actual que enfrenta la
relación entre China y Estados Unidos es
una preocupación para todos nosotros
las relaciones entre ambos países están
en uno de sus peores momentos en décadas
por lo que los mandatarios hablaron
durante cerca de tres horas entre los
puntos principales estuvo Taiwán
territorio que Beijing considera una
provincia Rebelde y que ha prometido
reunificar así sea por la fuerza la isla
goza del apoyo económico y militar de
Washington silimpin avisó a byden de que
no cruce lo que para china es una línea
roja este respondió
[Música]
yo creo que haya un inminente intento de
China de invadir Taiwán
también está la situación en la región
de Asia Pacífico Estados Unidos promete
reforzar su posición en la región si
china no actúa para contener los
programas armamentísticos norcoreanos
mientras que china no esconde su
molestia por la alianza aucus que dotará
de una flota de submarinosa propulsión
nuclear a Australia otro punto de
conflicto es la lucha comercial desde
Estados Unidos piden a sus empresas
reducir su dependencia de China mientras
que desde Beijing protestan por las
restricciones al acceso de productos
tecnológicos la guerra en Ucrania contó
con un punto de consenso
discutimos la agresión de Rusia a
Ucrania y compartimos la misma visión de
que el uso de armas nucleares es
totalmente inaceptable
los dos mandatarios llegan reforzados en
sus países vaiden tras retener el senado
en las elecciones de medio término y sin
pin tras ser elegido en el congreso del
partido comunista legitimidad con la que
deberán decidir si reconducir sus
relaciones o seguir por el camino de una
peligrosa escalada el presidente de
México Andrés Manuel López Obrador
defendió la reforma electoral de esto
después de las masivas manifestaciones
en las calles de la capital mexicana que
tuvieron lugar durante el fin de semana
y también en otras ciudades del país el
mandatario desestimó la protesta que
calificó de racista ahora la pregunta
que queda es si la iniciativa recibirá
apoyo de la bancada oficialista para
avanzar en el legislativo
Andrés Manuel López Obrador salió a la
defensa de su reforma electoral que
levantó la polémica en México luego las
multitudinarias manifestaciones del
domingo el mandatario respondió
catalogandolas como racistas y clasistas
y calificando la escena como un
striptease político Entonces lo de el
INE fue una
excusa una bandera los que se
manifestaron ayer
lo hicieron en contra
de la transformación que se está
llevando en el país
la propuesta de López Obrador contiene
múltiples aristas que generan
controversia y despiertan acusaciones de
querer acaparar el poder la más
importante es la sustitución del
Instituto Nacional electoral y la
creación del instituto nacional de
elecciones y consultas un ente que
centralizaría toda la Organización de
las elecciones y le quitaría el control
al gobierno opositores acusan al
mandatario de querer acumular poder como
el caso del presidente de la cámara de
diputados Santiago grill
las mexicanas y los mexicanos salimos a
las calles a defender nuestra democracia
levantamos la voz y dejamos muy claro
que no apoyaremos la de forma electoral
que propone el presidente México no es
de un solo hombre es de todas y todos
la reforma también apunta una reducción
de 200 diputados 32 senadores y que los
consejeros y jueces electorales se han
votados por el pueblo entre una lista de
candidatos confeccionada por el
presidente la Corte Suprema y El poder
legislativo por ahora el partido López
Obrador no tiene la mayoría
parlamentaria necesaria para que la
reforma avance pero se esperan intentos
para conseguir apoyo de legisladores de
otros partidos vamos a Colombia donde la
peor temporada de lluvias en 40 años
deja hasta el momento 205 fallecidos y
medios centenar de desaparecidos las
autoridades informaron que los 32
departamentos del país se han visto
afectados entre tanto en Bogotá la
capital la alcaldesa Claudia López
decretó el estado de calamidad pública
debido a los derrumbes e inu provocados
por las lluvias que según estiman los
expertos meteorológicos podrían durar
hasta febrero
el 26 de septiembre pasado Cuba aprobó
en referendo el nuevo código de las
familias una ley impulsada por el
gobierno de Miguel Díaz canel que avala
por primera vez los matrimonios entre
personas del mismo sexo y ha cambiado
miles de vidas
Cuba vive una nueva Revolución esta vez
en su código de familia aprobado en
referendo en septiembre cambió la vida
de Pedro Rafael Delgado de 56 años y de
Adolfo López de 62 años por fin pudieron
casarse siempre viví
con ese rechazo con ese dolor de que tus
propias familias y fuera los que te
censuraran en octubre Se realizaron 75
matrimonios entre personas del mismo
sexo son más del 2% del total de bodas
en Estados Unidos los hogares del mismo
sexo representan el 1,5 pero activistas
consideran que todavía hay camino por
recorrer la lucha también es cultural
una vez aprobada la ley Hay que seguir
trabajando con las mentalidades para que
los prejuicios sean poco a poco
desmontados la nueva ley también cambió
la vida de Ariana mederos está
estudiante de Medicina pensó que nunca
podría desarrollar su carrera cuando
hace unos años empezó su transición
la sociedad tiene un poco de avance que
yo lo he visto bastante marcado porque
las personas hoy como tal no se dirigen
a una persona trans como lo hacían antes
mirando sobre el ojo sobre el hombro el
referendo contó con gran publicidad y
apoyo mediático la mitad de 11 millones
de cubanos participaron en la discusión
del proyecto y tras su aprobación Cuba
se sitúa en la vanguardia de derechos
sociales emprendida antes en Argentina
Brasil Chile y Colombia
la ciudad de Nueva York sigue inmersa en
una crisis migratoria la urbe se ha
convertido en una de las principales
receptoras de personas provenientes de
Centroamérica y Suramérica Un aumento en
el flujo de personas que pone en jaque
su capacidad de brindar asilo Manuel acá
no tiene los detalles
la llegada de Gustavo Méndez a Nueva
York fue auspiciada por un político
republicano uno de los gobernadores de
los estados del sur le compró un billete
de bus que lo llevó al este a la ciudad
que se ha convertido en uno de los
núcleos de la migración latinoamericana
a Estados Unidos
era tan duro la selva o aparte de la
selva de enfrentarse a los demás países
las limitaciones que te ponen que
tuvimos en Nicaragua que tuvimos en
Honduras en Guatemala
la historia de Gustavo es similar a la
de más de 17.000 personas que han
llegado en los últimos seis meses a
Nueva York provenientes especialmente de
países centroamericanos y de Venezuela
su vida en una crisis migratoria la urbe
se enfrenta a la amenaza de desbordar su
sistema de Refugio
antes de este gran aumento de
solicitantes de asilo solía haber un
periodo de esperar de entre ocho meses y
dos años preveo que con la mayor llegada
de solicitantes de asilo al menos se
doblará
la ciudad liderada por el demócrata Eric
Adams tuvo que anunciar el estado de
emergencia en octubre
y el domingo la oficina de presupuesto
independiente de Nueva York aseguró que
sus gastos anuales para brindar Refugio
educación y atención médica a los
solicitantes de asilo se estiman en 600
millones de dólares unas cifras que
según el informe no estaban
presupuestadas previamente y que
necesitarían de mayores recursos
federales y estatales para poder
enfrentar la masiva migración es todo
por el momento en France 24 quédense con
nosotros
[Música]